hello my name is shadin dogmi and i'm
going to tell you how the matrix
secretary problem is equivalent to
contention resolution
let me start with a somewhat vague
description of my main result i show
that two statements are equivalent the
first one is the matrix secretary
conjecture which says that there is a
constant competitive algorithm for the
matrix secretary problem
the second statement concerns what is
known as contention resolution and it
says that contention resolution is
approximately as powerful in the online
random order model as it is in the
offline model and this should hold for
all correlated distributions not just
for product distributions
you might ask why this is interesting or
useful to know well first of all
it tells us that the matrix secretary
problem even though it features these
adversarial weights is actually
equivalent to a natural stochastic
problem
in particular the problem of contention
resolution
second it tells us that online
contention resolution in the presence of
positive correlation is actually the
core challenge of the matrix secretary
problem
and hopefully this opens the door for a
lot of the recent progress on contention
resolution to be applied to resolving
the matrix secretary conjecture
and finally
this tells us that the hard part of the
matrix secretary problem even though the
problem features cardinal weights
the hard part uses only ordinal
information about those weights
now to prove this result
i build on my recent work which appeared
in icalp 2020 and there i proved the
forward direction of this equivalence
namely that the matrix secretary
conjecture implies correlated contention
resolution in the random order model
and also i proved the weak converse of
that which which restricts contention
resolution to a more restrictive
model so in this paper
i strengthen this weak converse i
basically remove this clause
and therefore this establishes full
equivalence of these two statements
now for some background
the matrix secretary problem was
introduced by babaya formula and
kleinberg here you're given a metroid up
front
and then an adversary assigns weights to
the elements of the metroid
the elements then arrive online in a
uniformly random order and when an
element arrives arrives the algorithm
learns its weight and must decide on the
spot whether or not to accept the
element
the algorithm is constrained by
feasibility in particular the accepted
set of elements must be independent in
the majority
we say an algorithm is alpha competitive
if the expected weight of the elements
it accepts is at least alpha times the
weight of the offline optimum
here the expectation is over the random
arrival order
this problem generalizes the classical
secretary problem of thinking
and captures many online settings that
feature adversarial data arriving in a
non-adversarial order
the same authors stated the matrix
secretary conjecture which says that
there's a constant competitive algorithm
for this problem for all metroids
a lot of work has gone into designing
competitive secretary algorithms for
many natural classes of metroids this
includes the classes in this list and
many more
but the general conjecture remains open
and the best known for general metroids
is a competitive ratio of log log rank
duralishi
i'm going to note that the
metroidsecretary conjecture is an
information theoretic statement and
doesn't say anything about computational
complexity
and the same is going to be true
for the results i'm going to present in
this talk
so i'm going to relate the matrix
secretary problem to something called
contention resolution
informally here your task is as follows
someone gives you a draw from a random
set which is guaranteed to be
feasible on average for your constraint
also known as feasiblex anti and your
job is to convert it to a set which is
feasible always or feasible x post
let's make that a little more formal
there are three sets of inputs to a
contention resolution problem
first you're given the set system which
for us is always going to be a metroid
second you're given a distribution
capital d over sets of elements and i
don't really care so much about how this
distribution is represented because my
results are all going to be information
theoretic so think of it as some
description of the distribution but we
don't care so much about what it is
and third you're given a
a draw capital r from this distribution
d so r is a set of elements i'm going to
refer to it as a set of active elements
so if an element is in r i say that
element is active
now the output here is supposed to be a
subset of the active elements that is
feasible for the set system so for us it
will be independent of the metroid
independent in the matrix
so you can think of a contention
resolution algorithm as throwing away
some of the active elements in order to
ensure feasibility
and remember here we're only considering
a packing set system so by throwing away
elements you recover feasibility
now the simplest
setting here is the offline input model
where the set of active elements capital
r is given all at once
also interesting are online models where
the elements arrive in some order
pi
and when an element arrives it arrives
it shows up tagged with a bit that tells
us whether or not the element is active
and this is a stochastic bit because the
set of active elements is a stochastic
set
now if an element is active the
algorithm gets to decide whether or not
to accept it and it must do so on the
spot
our focus in this talk is going to be
the random order model where this pi is
a uniformly random permutation
an algorithm for contention resolution
problem whether it's online or offline
is usually called the contention
resolution scheme
and we judge such an algorithm by its
balanced ratio by its balance ratio
in particular we say the algorithm is
alpha balanced for a particular
distribution capital d
if it satisfies the following guarantee
for every element of the set system the
algorithm must select the element with
probably at least alpha times the
probability that the element is active
so conditioned on the element being
active it should be accepted or selected
with probably at least alpha
now
i should mention some notation here so
i'm going to use x sub i to denote the
probability that the element i is active
so the x the vector x is a vector of
marginals okay
of the distribution capital d
so the probability that i is
selected should be at least alpha times
x i
now a contentious resolution scheme is
typically defined only for some
distributions that are of interest right
so most prior work has focused on
distributions that are feasible on
average or x anti-feasible and those are
just and what that means is that the
vector of marginals is in the polytope
associated with the set system
and restricting to these distributions
is necessary for constant balance ratio
and that's not too hard to see well it's
necessary that this is be true at least
approximately i guess
most prior work also assumes that the
elements are active independently so
these x i's are assumed to refer to
independent probability events
and
this term it turns out is not necessary
and that's going to be a theme that's
important for this talk
let me now summarize some of the prior
work on contention resolution
contention resolution was formalized by
chicory von draken's inclusion and it's
been studied a lot since for various
set systems
and online and offline models
however
most of the work so far has focused on
product distributions in particular
anti-feasible product distributions
however those results typically extend
to negatively correlated distributions
for a suitable definition of negative
correlation
now the reason there's
the reason contention resolution really
took off
is because it turns out that it's the
technical core of a lot of stochastic
decision making problems and this is
shown in a lot of reductions in
literature in particular there's been
reductions for many families of from
many families who have problems to
contention resolution and this includes
all the families of problems in this
list here
now
if you read through the literature on
contention resolution you can glean the
following summary theorem
if your set system is simple enough then
you can get a constant balance ratio
so long as the distribution is x
anti-feasible and
it's a product distribution
this turns out to be true whether
offline or in any of the online models
that have been studied
and
this these guarantees also typically
extend to a negative correlation as well
for metroids the picture is fully
understood so the best balance ratio
offline and in random order is 1 minus 1
over e and for adversarial order it's a
half
now
recall that we said that x
anti-feasibility at least approximate x
antifeasibility is necessary to get a
constant balanced ratio therefore one
way to read the summary theorem is the
following
online contention resolution is as
powerful as offline contention
resolution up to a constant if all you
care about is product distributions
now if you remove this qualification to
product distributions uh you would prove
the metroid uh secretary conjecture
that's one interpretation of my results
in this paper
now even though a lot of this work has
focused on
independent
distributions it turns out that there
are some interesting positively
correlated distributions
where you can get
constant balance ratios
that's going to be
important for my results
let's now look at what happens when you
have positive correlation let's look at
worst case positive correlation first
and convince ourselves that for
arbitrary positive correlation there's
not much you can do
so let's now think of we have a
rank 1 matrid
on n elements and let's say all the
elements are active simultaneously with
probably one over n otherwise none of
them are active
this is feasible on average because the
marginals are one over n which is in the
matrix polygon up here
but it's pretty easy to see that nothing
non-trivial is possible the best you can
do is pick one of the active elements
uniformly at random and this gives a
balanced ratio of one over n and it's
clear that you can't do any better than
that
however there's some very interesting
and useful examples
where
you have a lot of positive correlation
but still you can get a constant balance
ratio i'm going to show you one of those
examples right now
let's say again we have a rank one
metroid and let's say the elements have
names 1 through n
let's say the set of active elements is
the set 1 through i with probability 2
to the minus i plus 1.
now
a simple calculation shows that this is
x anti-feasible because element one is
active probability half element two is
probability quarter and so on and the
sum of these numbers is at most one
however
you can also see that there's a lot of
positive correlation in this
distribution if you take two elements i
and j where i is less than j
the probability that j is active is to
the minus j but then if you condition on
i being active the probability that j b
is active goes up by a factor of 2 to
the i
which is quite a bit of positive
correlation
even though there's all this positive
correlation you can still get a
constant balanced ratio in particular a
balanced ratio of a half at least with
an offline contention resolution scheme
and here's uh such a scheme uh just
choose the large
the largest integer in the set r of
capital uh of active elements
okay
so um when the set of active elements is
one through i just select element i
now to see that this is half balanced um
all you have to notice is that when you
condition on i being active it's
actually the largest active integer with
probability roughly a half and this is
just a consequence of these
exponentially decreasing probabilities
here
not too hard to see
now even though this is offline it turns
out you can approximate it online up to
a small constant
using a dinkins secretary algorithm
and this is also not too hard to see
because notice that you're trying to
pick the largest
of a bunch of integers that show up
online and it's exactly the kind of
problem that is solved by a secretary
algorithm
i'm going to ask you to remember this
example this example distribution
because it's going to be important
for the rest of the talk
okay
now
this brings us to
some of my recent work on characterizing
offline contention resolution in the
presence of correlation
let me first
establish some terminology let's say i
fix a set system
i'm going to call distribution over sets
alpha and contentious if it permits
alpha balanced offline contention
resolution so this is just my shorthand
for a distribution that allows
alpha balance
via a offline contention resolution
scheme
now it turns out that
alpha and consensus distributions admit
a nice polyhedral characterization
and that's important for our results
so here's a theorem that appears in my
alcop 2020 paper building on a very
similar characterization of chicory
vondrak and zinklosin
let's say you fix a metroid
a distribution on
a distribution d on sets of elements is
alpha uncontentious if and only if it
satisfies a finite system of linear
inequalities and this system of
inequalities is indexed by a s by
subsets of elements
so i don't want you to focus so much on
the form of the inequalities just know
that this is a polyhedral
characterization of unconscious
distributions for matrix
now one nice thing about this
characterization is that if you stare at
it long enough you'll notice that it's a
generalization of a famous theorem by
admins known as the metroid covering
theorem
so let's now get back to our main result
and outline how we prove it
let's remember the main result as i
stated before
namely that the matrix secretary
conjecture is equivalent to the
statement that contention resolution is
about as powerful in the random order
model as it is offline
so i'm going to change the second
statement to a slightly more more
convenient form i'm going to say that
every metroid admits what i'm going to
call a universal contention resolution
scheme in the random order model
what does universal mean it just means
that you do about as well in the random
order model as you can hope to do
offline for every distribution so
there's a universal constant c between 0
and 1 greater than 0 such that if you
give this algorithm the description of
an alpha and contentious distribution
and a draw from that distribution
then that algorithm
achieves a balanced ratio of c times
alpha
again in the when the elements arrive in
a uniformly random order
so there's a weaker form of the second
statement that's also equivalent
which basically says that
all you need to do is do well for a
specific alpha
so
here i say there exists an alpha and
beta a specific constant alpha and beta
such that every metroid admits a beta
alpha universal contention resolution
scheme in the random order model and
beta alpha universal means that you
achieve a balanced ratio of beta for
every alpha uncontentious distribution
so it's enough to do well for a specific
alpha achieve constant balance for a
specific alpha
so it's it's pretty easy to see that the
second bullet uh implies a third bullet
the third bullet is just a special case
of the second one
um and um what happens is that all you
need is this weaker form of contention
resolution for a specific alpha in order
to establish the matrix secretary
conjecture and this is how all these
three statements are equivalent
i'm going to note that this result is
information theoretic and our reductions
may or may not be easy to make
computationally efficient and it's not
even clear at this point what
computational efficient means because i
didn't even tell you how you represent
these distributions as input
so
here are the two reductions
and these arrows are in the algorithmic
sense so the arrow from the top to the
bottom just means that i use
an algorithm for matrix secretary to
solve universal contention resolution
this uh this arrow on the right from the
top to the bottom was already in my
previous ical paper
and uses the fact that matrix secretary
essentially solves the dual of
contention resolution
in this paper i show the arrow here on
the left from the bottom to the top in
particular i use a universal contention
resolution scheme to solve the matrix
secretary problem
turns out to get this reduction
to work i need to break it up into three
component reductions
and this is to overcome a series of
technical barriers
so first i reduce the matrix secretary
problem to the metroid profit secretary
problem
and then i
produ reduce that to a generalization of
a contention resolution which i called
which i call labeled contention
resolution
and then i reduce labeled contention
resolution to the traditional unlabeled
form of contention resolution
and i'm going to define these problems
as i need them
okay let's now get to the proof
so i'm going to show you how to reduce
the matrix secretary
problem to universal contention
resolution or alternatively how to use
the universal contention resolution
algorithm to solve the matrix secretary
problem
i mentioned that i have to break up this
reduction but for now let's try and do
it directly and see what happens
i'm going to need a important definition
due to karger this is the definition for
the set of improving elements
let's say you have a metroid with
weights on the elements i'm going to
define the random set capital r of
improving elements as the set that you
sample as follows
first let s be a set of
half the elements chosen uniformly at
random i'm going to call the set as
the sample
and now define the set of improving
elements as the elements that improve
the offline optimal
on s
so i is improving if
it improves the offline optimal if you
add it to s or in other words if it if
it is in the offline optimal in this of
the set s union i okay
so
here's an easy fact about the set of
improving elements um basically the set
of improving elements hold half of the
optimal weights in expectation it holds
half the weight of the offline optima
and this is in expectation over the
sample capital s
and this is easy to see by the fact that
every element in the optimal is
improving with probability of half
so we can ask ourselves what does the
set of improving elements look like what
is its distribution
the easiest version of this question is
what happens for the rank 1 metroid and
let's say we have weights
w1 through wn in decreasing order
we already saw this distribution this is
the distribution we saw earlier where
the set of elements that are active is
the set 1 through i with probability 1
over 2 to the i plus 1.
so it turns out that the improving
elements are 1 through i with exactly
this probability
now we also saw that this set features
positive correlation but nonetheless
it is half uncontentious
it turns out that that's not a
coincidence in my ical paper i show that
for every weighted metroid the
distribution of improving elements is
half uncontentious and this is even
though
the improving elements feature of
non-trivial positive correlation
the proof of this using uses the
polyhedral characterization of
uncontentious distributions that i
mentioned before
i'm going to note that there's nothing
special about the number half here i
could have defined improving elements
for an arbitrary sample probability of
alpha
and that's important for the result but
for illustrative purposes i'm going to
stick with alpha equals a half in this
talk
okay let's now try to use contention
resolution to solve the matrix secretary
problem
let's say we're given access to a
contention resolution scheme
in the random order model that is
universal in the sense that it gives us
a constant balance ratio for all half
uncontentious distributions and this
will include distributions like the
improving element distribution as we
described before
here's what you do for the matrix
secretary problem
first you do something that's pretty
familiar for secretary algorithms you
observe the first half of the elements
as they arrive online and you don't
select any of them but you note their
weights we call this first half of the
elements capital s and we refer refer to
it as the sample
then in the second half as the elements
arrive you try and note the elements
capital r that improve the offline
optimum on the sample and you try to use
your contention resolution scheme to
resolve contention for the set capital r
of improving elements
let's make this a little more precise so
as the elements in the second half
arrive
for each one of them you can check if it
improves the offline optimum on the
sample and if so you call it active and
you feed it as active into this
universal contention resolution scheme
and then you
accept the element if and only if the
contention resolution scheme accepts it
now let's remember that improving
elements hold half of the offline
optimum value
and also let's remember that improving
elements follow a uncontentious
distribution in particular a half
uncontentious distribution so
our contention resolution scheme should
therefore work for them it should select
each of them with constant probability
so
since the
improving elements
hold the constant fraction of the
optimum and we select each of them with
constant probability then we should get
a constant competitive algorithm for the
matrix secretary problem
or do we
it turns out there's a bug in this idea
here it is
so the traditional definition of
contention resolution requires that you
give the scheme a full description of
the distribution up front
in this setting
we don't have a full description of the
improving element distribution because
it depends on these unknown
adversarial weights w on the elements
so for this uh for this reduction to
work we need our contention resolution
scheme to work in a more restrictive
model where only has a partial
description of the distribution of
improving elements at any point in time
and this is how things stood as of my
ical paper
the first thing we do in this paper is
that we fix this bug
so the problem was that
the distribution of improving elements
was unknown because we have this
adversarial weight vector
so we're going to instead assume that
the weight vector is drawn from a uh
known prior and what that gives us is
the uh what is called the metroid profit
secretary problem it's the same as
matrix secretary except that we're given
a prior capital w on weight vectors and
we're guaranteed that the vector of
weights little w is drawn from capital w
this problem was introduced and studied
for independently distributed weights by
assigning it all but we're going to need
to allow arbitrary correlation in the
weight vectors
it turns out that this relaxation
actually doesn't change the problem too
much
in particular the matrix secretary
problem reduces to this correlated
metroid profit secretary problem at a
loss of only a constant in the
competitive ratio so the problems are
essentially approximately equivalent
the proof is actually pretty easy here
it's just min max duality
we know that to do well for an
adversarial weight vector it's enough uh
by duality to do well for a stochastic
weight vector with um an arbitrary but
known uh prior distribution
now there are some technical details i'm
ignoring here
but
these only use us a constant factor
so
now we've reduced the matrix secretary
problem to a the metroid profit
secretary problem where we have prior
information on the weights and therefore
prior information on the distribution of
improving elements and hopefully this
now makes it easier to use a contention
resolution scheme to
solve the matrix profit secretary
problem
so we're going to now
use the same blueprint we have if we had
before
so we're going to assume we have this
universal contention resolution scheme
and
use the same kind of algorithm
except that now we know that the weight
vector is drawn from a
prior distribution that we're given up
front
so this is the same algorithm we saw
before
let's see now what happens
so for a fixed weight vector we know
that the set of improving elements is
drawn from a particular distribution and
we know that
the expected weight of improving
elements holds
half of the offline optimum and also the
distribution of improving elements is
half uncontentious
now when the weight vector is drawn from
a prior we just get a mixture of these
improving element distributions
and
linearity of expectation
preserves the property that we still
hold half of the offline optimum
now what happens to the
uncontentiousness of the distribution
when we mix it it turns out that's also
okay
because
it's easy to show using the polyhedral
characterization that uncontentious
distributions are closed under mixing so
everything kind of is preserved all the
properties that we need are preserved
but now we've bought something now we
know that
we know that the vector of weights is
drawn from a
prior capital w and we're given this
prior up front so what that means is
that we now know the distribution of
improving elements up front
and this is what we need for contention
resolution in the traditional definition
so now we can instantiate the contention
resolution scheme with this distribution
of improving elements
and
we can use it to resolve contention for
the set capital r
and since the set capital r
holds half of the offline optimum and
it's also half uncontentious
this contentious resolution should work
for it and should select each improving
element with constant probability
so therefore we should get a constant
competitive algorithm for the metroid
profit secretary problem
and by the previous reduction this would
translate to a constant competitive
algorithm for the metroid secretary
problem
does this work it turns out that
there's a bug here as well
okay
here's what happens
the weights now are no longer fixed
numbers but they're now random variables
if you have an improving element i
selecting it with constant probability
is no longer a guarantee that you're
going to
recover a constant fraction of its uh
contribution to the weight of improving
elements
and the way to see this is to look at
this blueprint for a bad example
let's say i is always improving but it
has small weight
equal to one with probably ninety
percent and large weight equal to say a
million with probability ten percent
you could have a uh 0.9 balanced
scheme that selects i precisely when its
weight is small and this scheme would
not recover most of
the weight of i
so we actually fully describe examples
where this phenomenon happens naturally
and
it can result in a contention resolution
scheme losing most of the weight of the
optimum
so the takeaway here is that even though
a contentious resolution scheme is
balanced it might
favor low weight improving elements when
these weights are stochastic
the way i'm going to fix this problem is
just by changing the definition of
contention resolution
i'm going to define labeled contention
resolution where each active element
also comes with a label and i'm going to
allow these labels to be arbitrarily
correlated with each other and with the
set of active elements
now i'm going to say a scheme is alpha
balanced if it's balanced with respect
to the labels as well so for every
element i it should be
the case that
the probability that i is accepted when
it has label l is at least alpha times
the probability that it's active with
label l
for the improving elements i'm going to
label them with their weights and
require the stronger notion of balance
and what that does is it gets rid of the
examples we talked about before where an
element is selected mostly when it has
low weight
it's not clear that we did anything
interesting here though all we did was
kick the can down the road and
what we did is just defined a new
possibly more difficult problem and
required the solution of that problem
however now we have this picture
we reduced matrix secretary to profit
secretary then reduced reduced profit
secretary to this stronger uh notion of
contention resolution labeled contention
resolution and it remains to reduce
labeled contention resolution
to
plain vanilla contention resolution
the first question to ask here is
whether adding these labels makes
contention resolution fundamentally more
difficult
in the offline setting the answer is no
and this is actually pretty easy to see
let's say you have a metroid like this
graphical metroid on the left and let's
say elements of the metroid show up with
labels and let's say the labels can be
one of three colors let's say
green blue or red
what you can do is you can define an
expanded metroid like this one on the
right where for each element of the
original metroid you create a bunch of
parallel copies one for each possible
label
and now labeled contention resolution
for the original metroid is the same as
unlabeled contention resolution for this
new expanded metroid
so if this element shows up labeled with
the color red that's the same as the red
copy of the element
being active
we can now ask whether we can do
something similar online
so let's think of the labeled contention
resolution problem where elements appear
in uniformly random order
and let's focus on a particular element
e
imagine that time goes from a 0 to 1 and
e shows up at a uniformly random point
on this timeline
when the element e shows up you get to
learn its label so let's say it's
labeled with the color red
now let's think of what happens in the
corresponding unlabeled version of the
problem
here it's not just the red copy of the
element that shows up but instead all
the different colored copies have to
show up in a uniformly random order
and
all of them have to be inactive
except for the copy that corresponds to
the
true label of red
now if you're trying to reduce the
problem at the top to the problem at the
bottom you'd have to somehow produce
this stream of data using only online
access to this stream of data
this it turns out is difficult okay
and the reason is you'd have to know not
to accidentally hallucinate the
inactive red copy somewhere here before
the true active copy shows up so if the
active copy is colored red you'd have to
make sure that you don't accidentally
guess the inactive red copy before the
active red copy shows up
we can show that this is actually
information theoretically impossible to
do
we also show that if you're trying to
reduce um this problem to this problem
you actually have you have to do
something like this uh to get any
guarantees
it might seem now that we're in a bind
but luckily it's a bind that we can get
out of
the solution is going to be to blow up
the metroid even more
so let's think of an element e
instead of creating one copy of the
element for each color what we're going
to do is we're going to create many many
copies for each color so we're
essentially going to duplicate each li
each label many many times
and the number of copies of each label
is going to go to infinity
so instead of having one blue copy of
element e i'm going to have many many
blue copies of element e and i'm going
to randomly splatter them throughout the
timeline
so now if you do this for every color
what you're going to get is a continuum
of colors where every color is pretty
much everywhere
and now this order is going to be
essentially deterministic so it's easy
to hallucinate hallucinate the order of
inactive copies
online
now whenever element e shows up
we can look at the time that it shows up
and look at its label let's say it's
labeled as red now all we have to do is
take whatever red copy of the element is
at is at that time and make it active
and this approach with a lot of
calculation we can show works
that's it for the proof
this is a picture we end up with
today i showed you everything on the
left here
i reduced the matrix secretary problem
to universal contention resolution going
through the profit secretary problem and
labeled contention resolution
if you combine that with my result here
from two years ago you would conclude
that all these four problems are
equivalent up to constant factors
so in closing we showed in this paper
that the matrix secretary problem is
equivalent to contention resolution in
the random order model for these
uncontentious distributions
this is interesting because contention
resolution is fundamentally stochastic
in nature and fundamentally ordinal in
nature
now the contention resolution problem we
get is particularly challenging because
of the positive correlation in the
inputs
however this positive correlation is not
arbitrary it's seemingly more benign
than a general positive correlation
and this is captured by our polyhedral
characterization for uncontentious
distributions
if we can somehow exploit that
characterization uh to resolve
contention uh in the random order model
then we would be able to resolve the
metroid secretary conjecture
and that's all i have thank you for
listening